what up guys at the airport right now
and before you guys think oh what an
exciting Vlog this is actually going to
be one of the most boring Vlogs you guys
have ever seen but it's gonna be one
where we're gonna level up
so if you're looking for a crazy
exciting Vlog this is not gonna be it
but if you're trying to level up like
the way that I am this one is in and as
you guys know this is a family vlog
we don't try to or I don't try to sell
you guys on anything I just document my
life whether I'm doing Bottle Brigade
stuff JK stuff buying houses raising a
kid I'm just sharing all the things that
I wish were shared to me and I just want
to pass on those insights to other
people now on to the leveling up part
so I'm about to fly to the most boring
place in the universe Ohio okay and the
highest peak that my parents have
accomplished my mom she has one rental
property so for me I always believe it
is the duty of the kid to surpass your
parents and over the last year or two
living in Vegas having sold our Las
Vegas house if you guys watched that
Vlog and watched how we made a million
bucks on it I've been able to buy a
couple of rentals and those are cash
flowing out which is super cool shout
outs to like websites and podcasts like
Bigger Pockets
um uh Preston from Legacy investing like
there's so much content out there to
help you grow your financial wealth for
your family right
now why I'm saving we're leveling up now
is now about to jump into like the big
boy game Public Storage so me and a
partner we've been scouting all over the
U.S and we found a pretty dope
undervalued property that has Public
Storage on it already without over 90
occupancy rate like I'm telling you all
these words are boring as but if
you care about leveling up it's about
falling in love with the boring right
AKA what uh Alex hermosi says so it's 90
occupant which means that it's already
um we don't have to worry about
vacancies that much but there's a ton of
areas for development so we're actually
gonna go visit the property to see how
we can one add more Public Storage which
is very easy to build to how we can bump
up the rents and then three how we can
cash flow this and really
set ourselves up for big financial
success for our family and this is
something that my parents have never
even been entered into this is something
my parents have never even done this is
probably something that's not even my
parents radar so I'm actually really
really excited because if I can make
this work check out the property and
share this whole experience with you
guys I think this will be something
that's extremely insightful that you
guys could take on into your own lives
if you guys are about leveling up then
hit the like button so that I know that
you guys want more content like this
right now I'm about to meet up with my
partner Chris who's big into investing
in real estate and he's the one that
actually put me on public storage and a
cool story how I actually met Chris do
you guys remember a few months ago I
posted that I was going to do this
mentorship program well I launched at
times 100 right and we had eight full
weeks of great discussions connecting
like-minded people people that want to
hustle that want to build either their
passion or really put their ideas and
plans to work
what Chris was one of the guys in my
program
and what I realized was although I might
know a few more things than him in terms
of social media and like pursuing
passions he knows a lot more than me
about investing in real estate so I was
like hey this could be a mutually
beneficial relationship
outside of this program so if you see
anything that seems like it has a lot of
potential hit me up he was like all
right cool so we're just chatting on
Instagram here and there and eventually
you'll start sending me some deals
apartment complexes and stuff like that
and sometimes these deals sound huge
right like Public Storage apartment
complex and it sounds huge coming from
California because everything that we
see is like dude that's got to be like
10 million or something like how can
anyone afford something like that
but in other states a lot of the states
are still very underpriced so we're
looking for opportunities where the
pricing is still affordable and where
people can get together because you
still see people like post all the time
right like the meme is the one percent
rule in real estate where whatever price
you buy the property at you want to rent
it for one percent so for example buying
a property for 100 grand
which you don't have to put 20K down if
that's 20 or if you have an FHA loan you
only have to put like three to five
grand down and you rent it for a
thousand dollars a month right those
numbers seem impossible in metropolitan
areas California New York uh even like
Texas or even like Vegas right but in
majority of the states if you know how
to look you can still find deals like
that so that's why networking is so so
important it's so important to like
surround yourself with like-minded
people because you don't know what you
don't know and if people can help inform
you what you don't know then that's how
you're able to build your success your
trajectory and all that so I'm meeting
up with Chris we've already had a bunch
of lunches together and I'm excited to
check out properties and hopefully have
him share some of the things that he
looks for and what he thinks or what he
thinks of this investment is good or not
see I ain't lying met up with my dude
Chris and we're going
to Cleveland it's funny to even say that
have you been to Cleveland before never
this sounds like a boring place already
you know but I booked us this awesome
Hotel yeah
there's actually some museums and stuff
to see around there oh cool it seems to
be closed but it should be it should be
a good time oh yeah I've been to
Columbus Ohio though so that was that
was a good time so hopefully uh we have
a good time here yeah I think we will
all right this is my first time on a
Frontier flight
there's some pretty interesting things
look at this chair it's like minimal
action
it's just uh it's dead
maybe it's to save weight
got these baby
almost futuristic looking back of an
iPad
table things
pretty interesting to see how every
single airline has their own take on
things I usually just fly Southwest it's
super easy but these seats are actually
pretty comfortable for Frontier although
is it normal that you always got to pay
for Cario
just becoming the norm these days yeah
you gotta pay for every little thing I
think that's one thing I still like
about Southwest even the uh the getaway
with me which is the cheapest one comes
with like two
two check-ins I think one carry-on but
it's pretty cool I like I like to see
people save some space and making making
the chairs a little bit thinner does
give me a little bit more labor room
which is kind of cool
all right so this is the property that
we're trying to look at how many acres
is it it's a little over six acres so
the whole property is six acres what's
awesome about this is the public storage
is over here
and so a lot of it is unused this was
used to be a like a motel or something
yeah a motel so it's a motel that's been
gutted out so we can import more of
these charge more right here and the
beautiful thing about this is that
there's so much extra space that we can
add way
so like our goal is to try to pretty
much if you guys are familiar with like
that she talks about like the Burr Model
A lot right like you buy something then
you create Equity into something then
you get it reappraised at the new
appraised value and you're able to take
out a lot of the equity that you forced
into it so that's what we're trying to
do where we have all this untapped
equity in the land and we can build all
much monetizing units and then now
instead of having like let's say 100
units now like let's say for example
we're at 500 units it's making way more
cash flowing way more as you can raise
that way more we can pull that money out
so what does it look like in real life
so yeah that's that hotel we're showing
you guys so it's just completely flat
here so I'm gonna have so many units and
that's the current
um are those the current ones right
there well that's another angle yeah so
that's what it looks like on the side
just white and blue super plain got a
gravel road that you could drive through
[Music]
so yeah pretty much we're going there to
make sure that the map is indeed what it
looks like it looks like he has a proper
acreage it looks like the quality that
we see in the photos and then also Chris
has been doing a really good job of
coordinating and getting like um
uh estimate for like construction and
getting a commercial lender on board to
do all of this kind of like project
managing the whole thing so we just have
to go and make sure that everything that
we see kind of ties in with each other
all right landed not too long ago it's 5
30 back in Pacific Standard time but
since we're on the East Coast it is
eight 8 30.
and so we're having a late dinner which
I'm starving so I'm glad we found this
really good Steakhouse we got this uh
shrimp scampi starter oh my smells so
good all right let's try this bad boy
you mind if I grab it which is my hand
first meal well actually technically
second I had breakfast
over there
oh my goodness look at that yeah garlic
I got chimichurri I don't even know I'm
gonna use that with all this garlic on
there we got
the uh brussels sprouts and broccolini
and then oh you got a big old rib eye
huh gotta go rib eye
all right so shout outs to this place
because they actually know how to cook a
steak look at that look at how much pink
there is
it's pretty much all pink and only the
edges are seared that is amazing good
job guys if you're ever in Cleveland
check out Red Red Steakhouse yeah red
just checked into my hotel super nice
damn Cleveland doing it right the
king-sized bed
so I'm gonna work on a little bit of
barbell stuff
and I'm gonna pass out wake up in the
morning head to the gym at five a.m I
still got to get my lift on
um because I'm trying to train and get
Elite this year I ain't around
and then we're gonna shower at the gym I
already called the gym pre-plan
everything because planning is
everything
called the gym they got a shower and
then go straight to the public storage
tomorrow so I'm excited to show you guys
the public storage because this will be
the first time that I see it in person
too see if it matches up and if it does
you could be looking at a future owner
of public self-storage randomly out in
Ohio I'm telling you guys we're making
big boy moves here okay we're leveling
up so good night and see you guys
tomorrow